bonsoir à toutes et à tous nous sommes
lundi 14 mars merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7 8 le journal
votre actualité locale quotidienne
accompagné deux invités mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite lé titre de cette édition
résultats de l'élection législative
partielle dans la 2e circonscription des
yvelines a eu lieu ce week end après la
démission de valérie pécresse dans le
département le parti socialiste se
maintient avec un score plus faible
retour sur les résultats dans ce journal
ils étaient 78 en septembre 2015 avoir
trouvé refuge à bonnel dans les yvelines
au monastère dorante six mois après que
sont devenus les réfugiés reportage à
bonal où le centre d'hébergement
accueillent toujours des réfugiés
afghans et tibétains et enfin la sixième
édition de la semaine de l'industrie
dans les yvelines et partout en france
une semaine pour parler de cette filière
en pleine mutation
cette année le thème est l'industrie du
futur pour nous en parler ce soir en
plateau notre invité jacques en pin et
élus de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines et pdg de
l'entreprise ont contre 6 et le 9
janvier dernier la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines procéder à sa
séance d'installation un nouveau
président et ses vice-présidents et est
élu un collectif de citoyens a saisi la
justice dénonçant notamment la violation
du principe de publicité de la séance le
10 mars le tribunal administratif de
versailles a décidé de l'annulation de
cinq délibérations dont l'élection du
président et de ses vice-présidents
écouter on est satisfait parce que parce
que c'est aussi au delà de la décision
ça montre que il est nécessaire vraiment
que tout le monde se remettre autour de
la table et qu'on arrête de manière très
claire des méthodes de travail
nous ça fait des mois qu'on demande à ce
qui est une charte de bonne gouvernance
pour savoir où on va dont par où on va
et comment
et ça nécessite de réfléchir ensemble et
c'était pas vraiment l'ambiance jusqu'à
présent donc on espère que ce jugement
va ramener chacun à la raison et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
mais sur le sujet pour l'instant dans
l'attenté de la notification du tribunal
administratif disposent d'un mois pour
faire appel de cette décision est
politique toujours trois élections
législatives partielles se déroulait ce
week-end après les démissions des
députés xavier bertrand et gérald
darmanin dans le nord pas de calais et
de valérie pécresse dans les yvelines
dans l'aisne et le nord le parti
socialiste est d'ores et déjà éliminé
dans notre département il se maintient
mais avec un très faible score les
précisions de wilfrid richy seulement
12,98 % pour le candidat socialiste
multiplication des listes à gauche et
dynamique nationale ont eu raison des
ambitions de tristan jacques dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
maire-adjoint de magny les hameaux où il
ne devance son adversaire de droite que
de 3%
il avait pourtant tenté de montrer ses
différences avec la politique du
gouvernement
insuffisant pour une candidature commune
avec europe ecologie les verts
l'une des seules formations en
progression par rapport à 2012 moi j'ai
profité de la plus grande part le ps a
divisé son nombre de voix par quatre les
républicains par deux et ce film on est
les seuls en ondes au nombre d'électeurs
qui maintenant on a à peine baissé
donc c'est une super nouvelle on donnera
pas de consigne de vote puisque les
électeurs sont libres de leur choix ça
s'appelle la démocratie et c'est très
bien comme ça
sauf surprise c'est donc pascal thévenot
maire de vélizy soutenu par les
électeurs de sa commune qui devrait
l'emporter sur l'ensemble de la
circonscription il totalise plus de 46%
ma campagne s'arrête pas quel que soit
même si on peut imaginer que
il ya de grandes chances que j'arrive à
l'emporter dimanche prochain mais c'est
ma nature et puis j'ai été à bonne école
avec valérie pécresse au dessus une
élection ça se gagne que le soir à 20
heures
donc là je serai encore sur les marchés
je serais encore en porte à porte
j'aurai encore des équipes dans toutes
les gares et j'en ai un je les
accompagnerai tous les matins un duel
droite gauche pour le second tour
programmé dimanche qui masque le
résultat du front national quatrième
devancé par benjamin lacombe issu du
mouvement yvelines pour tous la liste
manif pour tous
en réalité est un copier coller de notre
programme ils sont également contre
contre l'immigration massive ils sont
pour la social schengen ils sont pour le
débat sur l'euro on voit que nos idées
sont très présentes maintenant leur leur
présence à eux a permis justement au ps
de se maintenir et de rester au second
tour de cette élection on retiendra
surtout la faible participation à peine
30 % des électeurs se sont rendus aux
urnes
ils étaient 78 en septembre 2015 syriens
irakiens tous fuyaient la guerre et
avait été accueilli à bonnel dans les
yvelines au monastère dorante
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus là et ont
été relogés dans différentes villes de
france mais le centre lui d'hébergement
continue d'accueillir des réfugiés
afghans et tibétains et vivent depuis
plusieurs mois en communauté un
monastère qui est comme une première
étape pour leur adaptation à leur
nouveau pays
williams elle pour ce reportage donc là
c'est un étage qui est dédié à notre
communauté afghane
vous avez une chambre sont échanges
individuels sont des petites chambres
ils sont 73 à vivre ici au monastère des
orantes un pakistanais et deux afghans
et 59 tibétains des communautés
totalement différentes qui sont en
france pour la même raison
fuir la guerre dans leur pays d'origine
sonam et tibétaine et aujourd'hui elle
compte rester en france
si le tibet libéré je rentrerai mais
sinon je ne peux pas si je reviens là
bas je serai tué parce que là bas j'ai
pris part à des mouvements politiques
alors si je reviens je serai tué
tibétains
cohabitent dans ce centre d'hébergement
soit comme demandeurs d'asile ou
réfugiés statutaires
mais avec le même objectif rester en
france pour reconstruire leur vie
steve je dois rester ici je ne peux pas
rentrer dans mon pays ça n'est plus
possible je dois rester ici en france
j'étudie j'apprends le français j'ai
besoin d'apprendre c'est vraiment
important
apprendre le français l'une des
principales activités de ces réfugiés
tous les matins une association seront
au monastère pour dispenser des cours
[Musique]
l'objectif c'est de mai les laisser
devenir autonome au plus vite pour qu'il
puisse vraiment progressé trouver du
travail
s'intégrer plus facilement le but ici
bien sûr celui ci n'est pas de les
garder à bitam aeternam c'est juste une
période delà de leur vie qui leur permet
déjà de ceux de ce
reprendre d'essayer de de se poser pour
connaître un petit peu pour savoir ce
qu'ils veulent faire de leurs mains
nous avons donc des réfugiés statutaires
donc ça signifie qu'ils ont obtenu le
droit d'obtenir un titre de séjour de
dix ans en france est de travailler en
france c'est l'état qui choisit ensuite
de les déplacer dans un autre logement
ou une autre ville
pour l'instant les réfugiés qui vivent
ici sont totalement libres il participe
aux tâches ménagères et à des activités
mais peuvent sortir quand bon leur
semble sous réserve de pointer tous les
trois jours pour voir en afrique 60
bénévoles sont mis en association et qui
habitent tous dans la région et
particulièrement à bonnel je pense que
c'est un bon reflet de ce que pense la
population sur sur ce monastère géré par
l'association habitat et humanisme ce
centre d'hébergement est avant tout un
lieu de repos et d'adaptation en plus
des 60 bénévoles pour les ateliers et
cours de français huit personnes
travaillent ici pour prodiguer un
accompagnement humain et administratifs
une sorte de tremplin social dans le
renouvellement et aujourd'hui s'ouvre la
sixième édition de la semaine de
l'industrie elle se déroule jusqu'au 20
mars depuis 2011
elle permet chaque année au grand public
d'aller à la rencontre des
professionnels de l'industrie ce la
mission est de promouvoir et de
renforcer son attractivité et ses
métiers auprès du grand public et
particulièrement des jeunes et des
demandeurs d'emploi pour nous en parler
ce soir
en plateau notre invité jacques opinait
bonsoir mais cet élu de la chambre de
commerce d'industrie de versailles vinh
et pdg de l'entreprise contre le 6 alors
cette année le thème l industrie du
futur
un thème approprié alors qu'on sait que
la filière est en pleine mutation oui et
tout à fait c'est nous on part alors en
tout à l'heure la filière industrielle
automobile notamment est en pleine
mutation et de ce fait la semaine de
l'industrie est un moment privilégié
approprié pour populariser auprès des
jeunes et les demandeurs d'emploi le ces
filières industrielles
alors est-ce que les enjeux de cette
semaine aux inscrits qui a vu donc
partout en france un bon paquet dans les
mines à ce qu'elle a une dimension
spécifique sur notre territoire
on a toujours tendance à penser que
c'est toujours spécifique sur son
territoire ce qui est bien normal bien
que ce soit quand même général mais je
dirais que le plus particulièrement sur
notre filière automobile qui est
importante puisque je vous rappelle que
nous avons deux centres de production
important celui de renault flins et
celui de psa poissy qui sont aujourd'hui
en très grande mutation qui de tout
point de vue d'un point de vue de
l'appareil de production mais d'un point
de vue également des ressources humaines
nécessite vraiment un travail approfondi
une réflexion pour le futur et c'est
vrai que le vocable usine du futur et
quelque chose pour nous de très
important alors justement vous allez
intervenir mercredi donc la chambre de
commerce et dans l'esprit pour parler de
c'est un nouveau projet alors castaing
alors qu'est ce qu'un e
et bah écoutez c'est un regroupement de
différentes entreprises mais aussi des
services de l'état avec la direccte
l'unité territoriale des yvelines
la chambre de commerce les pôles de
compétitivité les réseaux filières comme
leur avis dans l'automobile afin de
trouver des solutions d'amélioration de
la compétitivité de notre filière
automobile
alors ça concerne particulièrement donc
à psa à poissy renault flins
il sait mutualisation comment ça va se
dérouler pour dire un peu plus sur ce
projet oui alors il y a quatre grands
volets dans ce dans ce pub vous avez le
premier volet qui est celui en fait de
la mutualisation à ce qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon la massification
qu'est ce que cela veut dire nous ne
rendons compte que nous pouvons gagner
beaucoup en compétitivité en
raccourcissant les délais en
raccourcissant les parcours entre les
équipementiers entre les
les constructeurs eux mêmes les
équipementiers de rang 1 et l'ensemble
des fournisseurs de la filière en se
rapprochant en ayant notamment des
locaux en commun pourquoi pas ce qui
permet justement d'abaisser les coûts
d'ensemble de la production la situation
que de la filière par rapport à
l'automobile mais plus globalement par
rapport à d'autres industries est ce
qu'elle est en décroissance dans le
département comme vous voulez analyser
ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui à la
chambre de commerce effectivement c'est
une un début de décroissance mais qui
doit pas non plus être je dirais
développer le pessimisme sur l'industrie
en général
la filière automobile est en très très
grande mutation vous avez dû voir il ya
énormément de d'évolutions
technologiques
sur l'ensemble des véhicules notamment
le véhicule électrique où tous les
véhicules électrifiés
mais également sur tous les véhicules
d'un point de vue de la sécurité
notamment
et c'est pas très étonnant
qu'aujourd'hui nous vivons ce changement
entre je dirais le véhicule
d'aujourd'hui d'hier la mobilité d'hier
et la mobilité d'aujourd'hui le but est
aussi de cette semaine c'est de parler
donc de cette filière aux jeunes est-ce
que c'est pertinent sont sous la statue
serait en mutation vous savez comment
les conseillers vers où ils doivent se
tourner s'ils veulent travailler dans
l'industrie mais bien sûr aujourd'hui
enfin on voit depuis des siècles et des
siècles que on peut analyser le
développement de l'économie il y a des
mots des phases de dépression et des
redémarrages et les phases de dépression
sont des moments qui permettent
justement de réfléchir de préparer
l'avenir et aujourd'hui de nombreux
nouveaux métiers apparaissent dans
l'industrie automobile comme dans
d'autres filières notamment le je pense
à la filière aéronautique et qui sont
aujourd'hui des pays qui ouvre des
perspectives importantes pour les jeunes
et les demandeurs d'emploi par rapport
aux absences ça qu'on soit vraiment une
filière automobile
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres projets de ce
type dans l'appartement qui a fait
d'autres pour notre entreprise
alors il existe pas dans le département
mais dans notamment fait la base et dans
un autre département puisque c'est dans
le 93 et dans le domaine aéronautique le
projet aigles qui est un projet
justement de mise en de mutualisation
entre les groupes et les pme qui
concerne quand même quelque chose comme
2002 1300 entreprises c'est quelque
chose qui procède de la même démarche
mutualiser pour gagner en compétitivité
sur le marché international la
mutualisation c'est l'étape importante
l'étape clé pour pouvoir amener notre
industrie plus loin d'être donné par
rapport à l'allemagne ou à l'angleterre
oui et si l'on prend des chiffres qui
font un peu froid dans le dos
aujourd'hui les dirigeants des unités de
production de psa poissy ou de renault
flins voit bien ils ne sont pas en
concurrence entre eux en fait ils ont
chacun leur je dirais lors de leur
propre marque à leur propre véhicule
ils sont en concurrence avec leurs
propres collègues des dans les autres
pays on prend le cas par exemple de de
psa psa est fortement en concurrence
avec leurs collègues en espagne renault
est fortement et encore plus fortement
en concurrence d'ailleurs avec leurs
collègues leur collègue basé en turquie
un exemple pour un véhicule coûte en
1200 euros en fabrication sur la france
donc sur les sites concernés yvelinois
nous avons un prix en espagne de l'ordre
de 800 euros et nous descendons à 450
euros pour le site renault de turquie
vous voyez ça vous donne vraiment la
teneur des progrès que nous avons à
faire est bien évidemment tous les tous
les acteurs de l'aide de l'économie et
en particulier les chambres de commerce
aujourd'hui vraiment à coeur deux ans de
s'investir pleinement dans cette action
de je dirais de de développement c'est
leur développement de notre industrie
soit les acteurs locaux sont très actifs
par rapport à l'état dont l'acteur
nationale le gouvernement faux cul comme
un peu de la filière industrielle il ya
d'autres choses à faire il doit pousser
l'effort
oui nous attendons bien sûr des pouvoirs
publics un effort plus important pour
nous accompagner dans cette dans cette
démarche mais je me serais quand même
que l'unité territoriale de la direccte
au niveau des yvelines a été vraiment un
acteur important dans le déclenchement
de cette opération du hub industriel
puisque c'est en fait la direccte des
yvelines qui a passé commande à la cci
pour lancer ce programme en fait une
dernière question avons terminé cet
entretien jacques opinait on parle
beaucoup de la réforme du code du
travail
c'est vraiment l'actualité est ce que
justement cette réforme pourrait changer
quelque chose pourrait améliorer
peut-être la situation pour à la filière
industrielle alors vous imagine que vous
faites référence à la loi elle comrie
alors cette loi initialement nous
semblait intéressante bien que très
insuffisante par rapport aux besoins de
notre économie
mais vous savez une chef d'entreprise
dès qu'il ya un petit problème quelque
part nous adhérons et nous le soutenons
ce que je crains toutefois vu les
derniers débats et les dernières
informations que j'ai eu c'est que cette
loi soit vidé de son de son compte de
son contenu maintenant c'est aux
politiques de décider
merci beaucoup jacques hopin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et d'être venu
sur notre plateau tous les événements
sur la semaine de l'industrie sont à
retrouver sur le site internet de votre
bandeau qui s'affiche juste en bas voilà
plus de précisions sur ce site internet
merci beaucoup et du 11 11 pardon au 18
mars également la semaine de l'artisanat
sur tout le territoire l'occasion de
mettre à l'honneur la première
entreprise de vous pensez de montrer le
savoir faire de nos artisans yvelinois
cette semaine nous vous ferons découvrir
trois métiers d'artisanat différents la
première de notre série
c'est isabelle est d'avis la souffleuse
de verre depuis 30 ans à triel-sur-seine
à l'aide d'un chalumeau
elle donne forme à cette matière
délicate et fascinante mélanie potier et
camille lambert pour ce reportage
l'un ce que je veux faire c'est pas rien
mais la masse est un peu pour que je
puisse récupérer un peu de matière
la poupée 1500 degrés c'est à cette
température qu'isabelle travaille le
verre quotidiennement en perles ou en
sculpture c'est aussi une matière
qu'elle façonne depuis 30 ans son
admiration est toujours aussi forte
le vert en tant que tel à partir du
moment où je vais travailler au
chalumeau
il a la même là même le même degré de
passion et c'est pas l'objet final qui
va faire que je vais préférer une pièce
à une autre c'est vraiment le travail
accompli au chalumeau entre mais demain
c'est de toujours avoir ce qu'on dira
cette appétence et c'est cette curiosité
pour ce verre qu'il faut quand même de
dompter apprivoiser la matière un geste
qui s'acquiert après plus de dix ans de
pratique
isabelle a fait ses débuts dans la
verrerie scientifique un milieu
technique mais qui laissait trop peu de
classe à sa créativité c'est dans les
années 90 qu'elle laisse libre cours à
son imagination dans la verrerie d'art
avec cette découverte de ce métier je me
suis dit je vais pouvoir lier un beau
métier avec le travail de mes mains et
ça c'était important pour moi je pense
que ça a été cette curiosité et ses
alliés en même temps gérer le côté
technique et le côté manuel le côté
créatif couleurs harmonieuses élégance
des formes la manipulation du verre en
fusion nécessitent adresse et patience
un art accessible par un ca paix ou un
équivalent du bac à bac + 2 certains
souffleur de verre propose même des
stages individuels pour transmettre leur
passion est toujours dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'artisanat aujourd'hui avait
lieu à versailles la cérémonie
officielle de remise de la médaille et
du diplôme de la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat des yvelines pour ce
palmarès 2016 plus de 50 artisans et
benoît ont été récompensés dans quatre
secteurs services à la personne services
de production bâtiment et métiers de la
gastronomie cire selon daniel varlet
président de la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat des civils quarante mille
personnes représentent l'artisanat dans
le département il était au micro de
camille lambert ça faire re découvrir
nos métiers la valeur de nos métiers
c'est peu de vous dire que nous sommes
la première entreprise de france
on l'a entendu sa publicité vraiment de
terrain la proximité la valeur des
artisans chacun dans leur métier mais ce
nous avons quand même 250 métiers
différents donc à tout un panel plus on
est nombreux plus on a dit dès et c'est
de mettre en commun toutes cette inertie
de nos de nos artisans yvelinois et nous
prenons la direction de saint cyr
l'école à présent la baisse des
dotations de l'état aux collectivités
locales est un fait d'actualité qui
inquiète les communes en septembre
plusieurs maires avaient manifesté
contre ces baisses dont le maire de
saint cyr l'école bernard de bain jeudi
dernier la mairie a décidé d'organiser
une réunion ouverte à ses habitants pour
évoquer la question des finances locales
fanny bourdillon pour les images
malgré l'annoncé du gel global des
fonctionnements et la diminution des
dotations saint cyr l'école se doit
comme toutes les communes françaises de
présenter un budget à l'équilibré des
décisions économique impacte la vie des
habitants
c'est pourquoi le maire a décidé de
parler finances locales et de les
convier à une réunion jeudi dernier
je suis venu plutôt comprendre ce que le
maire a présenté comme dj skee le
contenu à partie du contenu bon jeu
pourrait émettre des voeux des critiques
j'aimerais bien aussi que
les questions de logement soient plus
abordables entre 2012 et 2014 la commune
de saint cyr a perdu 200 3000 euros de
subventions selon le ministère de
l'économie et des finances la situation
oblige les élus à prendre des décisions
qui ne font pas forcément l'unanimité
notamment ceux qui concernent la hausse
des impôts
on va expliquer aux gens ce dans quel
état sont les finances de la commune
ça sera pas des choix unique il ya
forcément des choix dans la gestion il
va y avoir des choix dans
l'investissement c'est obligatoire la
réunion de ce soir c'est aussi pour
exposé aux habitants que nous sommes
obligés de faire des choix par rapport à
nos engagements
l'augmentation des impôts pourrait
compenser ces baisses de dotations même
si rien n'a encore été votée pour la
seule année 2015 la commune de saint cyr
l'école a vu diminuer son budget de plus
de cinq cent cinquante mille euros
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique culturelle du lundi bonsoir à
sephora nous sort fleurance et fort à
qui veut nous présenter un groupe qui
s'impose dans le paysage hip hop
français il s'agit de state of mind
exactement state of mind était à la
batterie de guyancourt vendredi dernier
pour un concert très énergique ils ont
littéralement enflammé la scène alors ce
groupe est formé de trois membres
autodidacte on avait green tea f qui
essayent de trois amis allemands
originaires de francfort qui ont démarré
le hip hop au sein d'un crew qu'il avait
monté au collège aujourd'hui
professionnel il parcourt le monde avec
des tournées internationales et
collabore notamment avec wax tailor
chinese man et de luxe wax tailor
considéré comme le chef de file du hip
hop cinématographique alors ils ont déjà
à leur actif deux albums platypus funk
sorti en 2010 suivie de crohn yards en
2010-2011 pardon et en 2015 ils sont
revenus avec un nouvel opus de chase
amulettes opus à partir duquel ils
produisent leur dernière tournée
leur style musical at il évolué alors le
style musical n'a pas vraiment changé
parce qu'ils ont toujours travaillé le
hip hop de leur jeunesse un époque plus
des années soixante dix avec des
influences jazz funk soul et reggae et
toujours cette dimension orchestrale
mais cette fois ci la nouveauté c'est la
dimension cinématiques qui encadrent le
projet ils ont créé toute une histoire
mythologique décliner aussi bien dans
leur clip que sur scène avec leurs
costumes ils nous expliquent pourquoi
ils ont développé cette proposition
artistique notre instrument
si tu veut cesser les monts et pour nous
on a toujours cru que dans on a toujours
pensé que dans les pop
c'est très limité la thématique pas par
rapport à la littérature la poésie
classique et c'est beaucoup des pops et
très basé sur les égos et moi je parle
de moi et je suis le meilleur parce que
moi moi moi moi moi et mon quartier bam
et c'est pas très intéressant au bout
d'un moment et nous on bosse on voulait
explorer un truc plus en thématiques
plus universel c'est donc une odyssée
hip hop cinématographique avec le récit
d'un monde chaotique entre péplum film
de samouraï odyssée d'homère f pied chez
lui le personnage central de l'histoire
qui porte sur lui la fameuse amulette de
jade et doit livrer une lutte entre les
forces du bien et du mal
win qui est le narrateur et les
différents featuring constituent les
autres personnages de l'histoire
[Musique]
alors le projet artistique de dépasse la
scène musicale parce qu'ils ont prolongé
l'histoire de charlie mais son ami
mettre au travers de leur clip oui tout
à fait vraiment leurs clips sont des
animations façon bande dessinée mêlant
parfois des scènes bien réel pour
plonger le public dans une confusion
entre réalité et fantasmagorie on
retrouve des dessins sombre qui rélève
le décor et les personnages de l'univers
épique de l'histoire
[Musique]
ils ont même tiré à partir de cette
épopée fictif de la mulette de jet d'une
bd de 40 pages fourni avec un double
vinyle et une représentation de la carte
du royaume où se déroule l'intrigué
ça fait un peu penser au groupe gorillaz
sephora en tout cas ils seront en
tournée si vous voulez les voir pour de
jay d'amulettes tour partout en france
jusqu'à l'automne prochain toutes les
dates à retrouver à l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran merci
beaucoup c'est faudra pour cette
découverte on vous retrouve mercredi
pour un nouveau nouveau numéro de
kiosques de quoi sera-t-il question un
petit teasing
alors on va retrouver bien sûr les
itinéraires poétique parce que vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'en ce moment
se déroule le fameux printemps des
poètes est également en scylla que vous
avez pu voir sur vos écrans samedi soir
dans the voice finaliste de la saison
dernière qui serait également avec nous
au plateau une grosse tare en plateau et
que des flics que d'exclusivité merci
beaucoup fait faudra tout de suite vous
retrouver michael et demi d'euros pour
la quitter et sportive avec le 7-8 sport
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
je remercie nous avoir suivis je vous
retrouve demain pour un nouveau numéro
du journal geos est une excellente
soirée